i unfortunately have to tell you that we
are uh
uh
at time and that means
uh that it's time for a talk so
i know that we're in day three i know
that we're kind of like running down uh
to the end uh i know that there's only
been one bomb scare so far so you know
like let's see if we can keep bringing
that thing out and i know that
we had some lunch we've got some other
things going on i don't know how the
energy is in this room so i do want to
find out how the energy is
in this room so hi ndc
[Applause]
that was actually pretty good that was
actually that was actually pretty good
okay so glad to meet you i have
uh been uh at uh uh touring around to
different ndc's uh first in porto uh now
in london and uh so excited to be here
my name is lemon and i make websites
uh i've been making websites for around
about 20 years or so sometimes i'm
you know pretty damn good at it
sometimes
well there's there's some websites that
i've made that i would not personally
cop to but i've been making websites for
a long time i still love it the the
communication medium of the internet is
so wonderful and exciting to me i love
the fact that websites mean that you
don't have to enter some sort of walled
garden where some app store can say oh
we don't like the way your icons are
you don't have any right to tell me what
i can do with my website if i want to
make a bad website i get to make a bad
website and the only thing that happens
is well there's two things that happen
either nobody sees my bad website or a
bunch of people see my website
um
but uh but i've been making websites for
uh quite a long time and uh and
and i use a bunch of different
technologies to do that exact thing um
so i personally uh
write a lot of my code in pug i don't
know if any of you all have seen pug
but as an html preprocessor very very
similar to hamel um kind of looks a
little python-esque with the indentation
based thing um it's basically just html
but faster and i've enjoyed pug very
much i also really really like sas um
i i adopted sas uh really early on um
when uh
doing the actual uh pre-compiling of it
was a lot more of a process than it is
now sas getting sas into a project is
really really easy and again it's it's
not that you're
extending you're you're learning a new
language it's that you're extending out
a language that's already beautiful
you're extending out css and i find that
very exciting um i do also write a whole
lot of view um
i was looking at different you know
those different frameworks the the react
and the and the angular and the view vue
was just the one that made the most
sense to me so it's the one i kept going
with but also i found some corporate
clients that needed me to write some
member well okay i'll figure that out we
can write some member no problem there's
also lots of situations where a client
is going to just say well we have
this.net project and we need you to
write you know some c sharp okay awesome
well they'll just write some c sharp
plenty of times though you'll i'll end
up writing a website where i have to be
writing php
uh because you know there's some sort of
cms that's going to exist out there and
that cms is
almost invariably imbrocco exists other
other things exist but almost invariably
a cms is going to end up in being in php
um i don't do it nearly as often as i
used to but uh but i used to for a while
to give myself sort of like little
handholds to start with i use something
called bourbon uh bourbon
sass mix in that just sort of like gives
you some sort of like
very early footholds to uh to go with
that it's a little bit deprecated now
but i do still do reach for it i do
sometimes reach for bourbon
or beer
or a gin
but all of those whoa we just went right
to the end but all of those
uh those uh platforms except for the two
that i just made up right in this moment
uh boiled down to three
essential facts three unbreakable facts
of web development uh that you need to
be uh cognizant of and those three facts
are html javascript and css no matter
what you're doing no matter what sort of
like of like ruby micro service or or
java monolith kind of thing as long as
you're making a website no matter what
it is you're going to be boiling that
down to html javascript and css if you
observated away that's cool but those
languages will still exist
and of course we're going to be talking
about the css part of it because i think
that
no man that's not that's not that's not
true at all i would never ever ever ever
say out loud
except for facetiously in this example
uh that css is easy css is not easy um
in uh in uh the words of dave rupert uh
one of the co-hosts of uh of shop talk
show he said he said css is
is pretty easy the only thing you have
to do is remember about 45 000 key value
pairs and then you're good good to go uh
css is not easy no but css is great it
is an interesting dynamic language that
is incredibly powerful and i think that
that is what always excites me about it
so uh
you're probably familiar with this gif
and i know that you've seen this gift
before and and i've seen this gift
plenty plenty plenty of times before
people tweeted at me and i'm not saying
i don't get it i do get it the entire
point of this talk is that i do
recognize these frustrations that put
this thing to light because they are
real
you can tr you can get tripped up with a
lot of css weirdness but what i'm going
to try to do
is change some mind so i want to start
off here if i may uh and i wanted to
just do an honest raise of hands this
talk of course is called uh i'm gonna
make you stop hating css and by a raise
of hands i want to just see how many
people genuinely would say that they
hate css they hate it wow okay all right
all right we've got okay that's fair
that's fair i get again i get i got to
get on sir i totally get it it is a
valid thing to hate css but what i'm
going to try to do is i'm just going to
try to tell you some things that are
more interesting about this and make it
more graspable and make you think of it
a little bit more like this because css
is just a series of rules that when
those rules are applied to the dom
interesting things happen in succession
so today's agenda uh we're gonna do a
couple things here number one is uh
we're gonna talk about things that are
weird uh css is a spec that's existed
for
multiple decades uh and it is an
additive spec it is not a spec that ever
gets
uh removed from uh every change that's
made to css is an additive change so
that means that things sometimes are
weird we're gonna move into some things
that are great because there are great
things about csfs if there weren't then
this would be a weird ass talk
uh and then we're going to close out
with some things that you can try now
because if you want to sort of level up
your css skills or just get a little bit
more of a feeling uh of those things
i've got some recommendations that i've
personally used and have recommended to
other people so with that said let's get
weird
uh this of course is uh the band uh
focus uh
singing a song called hocus pocus uh if
you're wondering that's interesting a
song called hocus pocus by the band
focus i wonder what those lyrics look
like those are the lyrics
somebody wrote that down like
that's not that's not google didn't do
that google google would have tried to
turn this into words they would have
tried to make sense of it a human being
went
yo dey a dodo
joe people have to know man people have
to know i mean if you're not posting on
the internet then really what are you
doing with your life um one of those
things that is weird is the concept of
overflow and the concept of overflow is
i think best is best to find uh by
another image that i'm pretty sure
you've seen in your life and that image
is this
i know maybe maybe you've seen this
before maybe some of you owned this mug
i've definitely seen this mug in person
i do not own this mug uh even though
people have tried to give it to me and
this is
totally totally reproducible in css in
fact not only reproducible it's
reproducible very easily so i'm just
going to reproduce this thing in css so
i'm going to say i want to make a box
and my box is going to have a border of
0.1 em solid white if you're not
familiar with the concept of ems you can
do units that are sort of like rather
than pixels uh or whatever you can do
something that's relative to the actual
m size
uh by either em or ch and so you're
saying i care about the font size in
this measurement so therefore the font
size changes uh you should change with
it to the same stick we're gonna say
that our uh the width of our box is
going to be 4 am and our padding about
0.3 am um so that all taken care of and
then we just got our html
and there we go uh we made it um it is
that is that is that graphic that you've
seen before that is definitely the
output of css
so that's something that we have to fix
now we have to fix that design
okay cool well there's a couple ways to
do that first of all we can say overflow
hidden
uh very simple concept of just you know
you like i've got a box and my box is
this big and if something's bigger than
this box just kick it out it goes away
hide that it's overflow hidden and
we do that and then we get this which is
i mean layout wise it's okay but it's
definitely not pulling our message
across like we're not actually getting
our message across the css is awesome so
i wonder if there's another way to do
this so we're gonna try instead overflow
y hidden
so when we state uh concepts like
overflow that have an x and y axis by
saying that overflow y is hidden what
we're saying is overflow x therefore
isn't and so i'm going to say if
overflow y is hidden which in this case
it would be
the y axis you can go ahead and scroll
that or not it's totally up to you
browser i'm gonna let you do this i'm
just gonna change the value of overflow
why and so in doing that
we get
this which like
i mean
okay so like that's
well that okay i mean that's
that kind of got our message across uh
but i wouldn't say that we've fixed the
problem we really haven't solved the
design problem here so okay let's keep
going
word break break word word break break
word is actually a property that exists
in css and when i say to you css is
weird this is what i mean you have to if
you're going for this idea you have to
type into your ide word break break word
and by the way
everybody involved in the css spec that
wrote that went
sorry we really should have called that
something else that was a mistake but
you know you can you can go ahead and
live with that we do word break break
word we're saying okay well you know
usually you're going to just take uh any
word and just like extend that thing out
i want to break that rule now and you
can just go ahead and just smash that
word down together and then we get this
and so like that's you know i mean like
that's a kind of
more of like a you know like a shopping
mall like a like a upscale like shopping
mall kind of stunning shirt and that's
and that's something but again we still
haven't fixed it we still haven't fixed
our problem let's keep going let's keep
going we've got uh text overflow
ellipsis
uh so i can say that you know this is
something that actually ends up really
really useful if you end up doing some
sort of like uh sort of smooshed
together like table or something where
there's like way too much content uh you
can say okay well uh go ahead and you
know and let that text go but if it gets
to the end i want you to just put an
ellipsis at the end of that and let it
go like that you can also like change
that effect on hover so for example you
can have like a table header text
overflow ellipsis and you hover on it
and then it shows you the actual thing
uh totally possible in this case we've
got css
css
let's go back to this rule
so
we started this thing out here we said
we were going to have a border
and that border was going to be white we
said we'd have a padding that makes
sense because we don't want our actual
text to smash into our border um but
what we had right here
was a defined width of 4em
we said that the box had to be this big
and then we put objects that were too
big inside of the box this in fact never
was a css problem it is a design problem
there is no conceivable way to hang out
that design and still have it make sense
your box is too small so we can just go
ahead and remove that property and then
we end up with this which i definitely
still do
think that it is i've got the idea for
this from a blog post on css tricks uh
so i'm going to talk about again in a
little bit because i do always find it
really really useful um
another concept here is the concept of
position
uh which also can be a little bit
confusing for sure so for example
there's uh there's a couple of different
uh position properties
and uh if i so if i like throw a div on
the screen
if you're really good at css i'm gonna
have to be quiet for just a moment here
but if but if i throw just a just a
regular old div on the screen
and i don't give it any property what is
the actual initial value of that div
any guesses glenn you gotta guess okay
glenn doesn't have a guess either
relative is a great guess but totally
the wrong guess thank you so much you
stooge you walked in here and i
immediately just called you out for
having a wrong answer because that was a
trick question uh the correct answer is
that the initial value of a p of a div
of an
abbr of of sort of like uh almost any
element i can think of is going to have
a position of static a position of
static is very close to position of
relative but worse we're going to go
through why here so for example we've
got our relative position div and this
is doing exactly what you think right
we've got a box i gave a little bit of
margin and then i'm going to go ahead
and scroll that thing down and we we've
got a box we've got a box on a grid
that's very exciting uh now we've got an
absolute positioned uh
box now this absolute position is going
to be positioned
to its nearest restrictive element so
for example
if i have a
uh an absolute positioned uh
little uh circle here up in the corner
and then i do an absolute positioned um
uh star inside of that circle that's
going to be its nearest restrictive
element so if i do a top it's going to
be 5 pixels at the top of
of that holding container if it doesn't
have a restrictive element it's just
going to accept the body so it's going
to stick itself to the body that's where
the static thing comes in
you move on and uh we've got position
fixed uh position fixed is a situation
where you're working at your job and
everything's going okay and then and
then some guy in marketing comes over to
me and goes uh
and goes hey um uh i got a question for
you when people come to the site
how do we do the thing where like the
box comes up and it says please enter
your email
uh the correct answer that is don't you
go that's impossible that's actually
never been done before they must be
using some sort of platform and we
probably have to pay for it like that is
emphatically evil and emphatically bad
but if you need to do it and you lose
that fight position fix is the thing
position fix will never care about any
bounding
element it does not position fix does
not care about the dom it doesn't care
about the body it doesn't care about any
containing element it only cares about
the screen which means that if i go
ahead and just scroll
uh in the screen position fixed go ahead
and stays there
a little bit similar to this and
something that for a long time people
were doing with javascript is actually
positioned sticky
position sticky is very very cool
because it is both a relative and a
fixed element
you can give a position's fixed position
sticky element a a margin of top bottom
left right you can also give it an
absolute of top bottom left right and it
will toggle between these things so in
the case of my position sticky right
here i've got it uh margin from the top
i've got a margin from the left and it's
gonna work basically like in a relative
element except for when that hits the
top it's just gonna stay there now again
this is the kind of thing that people
have been doing a lot of complicated
javascript to get uh to wrap that thing
around and that was necessary for quite
a while
but in the last uh
i would say four years now position
sticky exists and can
stack on top of itself you can do
position sticky inside of position
sticky elements so that they can
carry their own relative inheritance and
it works very very good
and then finally
we've got position static which is the
same thing that we saw in the beginning
right
so if we look at all five of these
things together
we can see that these things operate
slightly differently except for our
static and our relative element uh state
stay together with each other
so if we look at uh
if we look at those things uh this is
what these
all look like our relative is going to
follow the page flow and provide a
restrictive parent and our static is
going to be the same as above it's just
going to be less helpful so then you're
looking at that and you're going well
okay
with all of that said well
what's the difference
we've got in the case of a relatively
static element i don't know if you've
ever had this problem but you'll you'll
be laying out something and you and
you've got these little boxes and then
you want this box to be on top of this
box and this box is behind this box
and you go okay well uh z index nine and
it's like no and you're like okay cool z
index nine nine nine no
z index nine nine nine nine nine god
damn it what is winning here when you're
doing that the thing is is that is that
your static element is going to ignore
this value so you can you can play with
that z index all you want it's just not
going to do it your top bottom left
right also it won't care you give it
those elements and the and the position
static does not care about those things
it also will not hold an absolute it
will not if it's got an absolute
container inside of it it'll let that
absolute container bound out
so why does it exist well because we
were talking about in the very beginning
uh css is an additive spec as long as
that continues to be the case it does
continue to be the case um so one thing
that happened for example uh many many
years ago as a lot of people did these
uh css resets where for example uh you
would do like uh asterisk uh border box
and then that means that if if a box has
a width of 300 i mean the box is a width
of 300 i don't give a about padding
i don't give a about border i want
the box itself to be a width of 300. and
you can do that and make things a little
bit more sane so you also could do for
example this and say well okay we're
going to start out things and before
anything goes i want you to just put
everything as position relative and you
can do this
the only issue that you might run into
is that if you
are working with other people's code
which we all tend to do from time to
time you might run into a situation with
that containing element because if
you're looking at code where there was
supposed to be a static element and an
absolute element isn't supposed to be
inside of it and bust out that's going
to break so i would say before trying
this which totally again is a valid
approach
there's one of those things where it's
like oh you know it's technically a
performance hit as long as you have like
45 kajillion divs on the screen okay
cool but like if you want to do this uh
you totally can uh but you but what
might be a little bit better is if
you're struggling with something if
you're struggling with the margin if
you're struggling with the z index just
add position relative and so many times
it's going to fix that problem i wrote a
codepen article on that uh if you want
to read more uh and see some actual code
examples behind this thing but i want to
move on to a third
and hopefully
most important thing that is weird
which is float when i look at float
i don't actually see it like that that's
not what float looks like to me
what float looks to me
is like this
now float was a property that was made
many many many years ago uh sort of when
you know the idea of uh e magazines were
a thing uh and it was really made for
one thing the entire uh concept of float
was if we've got a picture
and we want to wrap some texture on the
picture
that's what a float is
so we can do that exact thing right so
i'm going to lay out some a semantic
article i'm going to give this thing an
image and i'm going to say okay i want
you to get a float left over there i'm
going to have a source and i'm going to
do some paragraphs and
if i do just that simple bit of markup
with our float left then
it's fine that's what we want right
we've got our picture
uh of tina uh we've got uh something
that a friend of mine created called
tina ipsum which is just randomly
generated quotes from tina belcher of
bob's burgers
and
that text floats around that everything
looks great this is a viable web page
but we can take that exact same thing
and by only messing with the contents we
can make something terrible happen which
is this
so this is the exact same thing except
for instead of our three paragraphs we
now just have one paragraph
so
that's not great like that seems like a
strange thing
and the reason why this is happening is
that you you you have a floated element
then you've got this first paragraph and
the first paragraph says okay well i
want to take care of that floated
element and i'm just going to loop
around here and then it's done and then
your container element goes well i'm
done too and it's like awesome we were
floating right here just go ahead and
close that thing out and this will
happen so frequently with floats this is
such a straight like a
a um
endemic problem to two floats
there is a fix
there is a fix and if you're doing
anything in
uh somebody else's code base especially
something that is float based uh
this code actually exists somewhere in
there
so if you don't know uh every element
can have a pseudo element actually two
different pseudo elements both a before
and and after
so i can say
i can make a div and then i can make an
after element and i can say
okay so i've got this container and it
might contain a float and so i'm a
little worried about that so i want you
to create a uh a a after element i have
to give it some content but we're not
going to give it really any content
we're going to say that it's got a
display table and we're going to clear
both the left and the right side and by
doing just that hack and it is
totally a hack
uh we've actually got this thing fixed
just with that line of code
which is nice except for like why does
this work
and why this works ends up getting sort
of philosophical because
we've got now a situation where here is
our article
and this is our after element so our
image starts here we've got a paragraph
here and then our after element which is
something that we just can't uh put in
to say we want to make a clear fix
because there might be a float over here
we're going to say here's a table
that exists in theory
please don't bother to render it there's
nothing to think about with this table
but
this table should have both a clear a
clear left and a clear right and by
doing that we can actually fix
this specific layout problem and make
essentially a float layout
so to that end i mean let's just make a
layout with floats like we did it right
we
we put three lines of code in we can
just fix our layout problems forever and
so all we need to do is we just need to
create a web page like twitter did this
that's what bootstrap was bootstrap was
a completely float based layout
there was so many uh frameworks that
were exactly float based layouts we can
do that as well and so what we need to
do is we just need to make a web page
and a web page is of course
uh
pictures of william reicher with quotes
from william riker so
there we go we've made our web page
we can cause a diplomatic crisis but
he's pretty happy about that he doesn't
know if someone could survive inside a
transfer buffer for 75 years
uh but uh my favorite of this always was
wharf
it's better than music
it's jazz
so
this is what we're trying to do we're
trying to make a layout with pictures of
william riker quotes from earlier riker
and we want to do this with floats and
so now that we've got our clear fix
we're in pretty good shape i mean
there's some code involved in this we're
going to say that every uh every riker
is going to float to the left
it's going to have a width that is
calculated now some people don't know
that this exists inside of css but it
does that it's very very robust you can
you can tell the browser to do math
and the browser will do it
like you can give it a calculation and
the computer will go like yeah okay i
think i got that
so uh even i.e even ie will actually
calculate things correctly almost all of
the time um
so we're going to say that every riker
has a width of 33 percent of the screen
uh we're going to we're going to
subtract 30 pixels from that because we
want to give a margin and a left
to each riker so that there's a nice
little
gap between them and that looks i mean
fine so now we can just go on to oh
okay
well that layout is no good that layout
stinks
um and this is one of those reasons why
if you've used uh one of those
frameworks like uh
bootstrap no longer does this they
changed some of that although actually
they keep a lot of that html structure
anyway
but one of the reasons why if you're
ever looking through
that bootstrap code and you're wondering
why there's so many container elements
or if you've ever given yourself the
pleasure of doing inspect element on any
facebook page
there's a thing that can actually
visualize like how deep in the dom you
are and like and like every div is like
layered in like 45 deep twitter twitter
especially tweetdeck we'll layer things
like literally 80 deep to actually get
to your tweet it's insane
but one of the reasons why that's
happening is that we basically just have
to create a bunch of container rules
because we're like well we want to be
very explicit
about what this content should look like
which is not what css should do
css should take arbitrary content
hopefully
crumbly written arbitrary content and
fix it
so there is hope here and that hope
actually has two forms and one of those
forms is a css grid uh css grid is
such an impressive powerful tool uh that
was added to the css uh css spec uh
three
three no no no no no
uh
it was out of the css spec a number of
years ago and it is a tool for actually
making a grid and it works incredibly
well incredibly deftly and very very
succinctly
so we're going to make our riker layout
again
but we're going to start over so we're
just going to say that we've got a
container element and then our container
element we're going to say here's all my
rikers
and we've got a display of grid we're
going to make some columns i'll get to
those in just a moment and then i'm
going to put a gap in there so that was
step one and then step two is uh we're
done actually we're totally we've
finished our entire layout um
when i was actually doing the example of
what i wanted this layout to look like
so that other people could see like the
thing that we were trying to make i did
that in grid because this layout is in
grid and is 288 bytes all told
that's that's pretty amazing
so there's a bunch of ways that you can
uh express your grid uh and we're going
to talk about the columns so so
our columns that are that are expressed
in grid can be done one of a couple ways
and we've got uh like a multiple of
different writing uh frs and fr is a
fraction we're going to get to that in
just a moment uh we can write the same
thing but just in a little bit of a
shorthand uh we can kind of mix
different units of measurement and
create a grid that way
we can repeat an element and say you
know go ahead and create columns as deep
as you like with this particular width
and we can also even give min min max
values to that so i want to go through
each of those and uh and this is going
to be talking about a very important uh
piece of uh of uh content that came in
the in this in the grid spec and that is
the idea of a fraction
so a fraction says um that there's a
number of space that you've got you can
do rows you can do columns you can do
whatever and you say hey browser uh
you've got i don't know maybe 860 pixels
i'm not going to get real specific about
it i just want one fraction of that i
want two fractions of that i want three
fractions of that and so you can just
take and mix and match these things and
that fraction is really just meaning
whatever's left
so to explain that i actually would like
to bring you the recipe of my gin and
tonic now i'm not a fancy person by any
stretch of the imagination i just like
to drink
um and i do like to drink gin and so
when i make a gin and tonic basically
i'll use four ice cubes because i like
it nice and cold
i'll do a jig or a gin uh i'll do
a lime wheel and then i'm just gonna use
tonic water like however much i've got
like is this one of these little glasses
is this one of these big glasses i'm not
really sure i'm just going to use an
amount of tonic water and in order to do
that when i've got these different
measurements i can still make that same
gin and tonic no matter what kind of uh
what kind of glass i have
so
so let's look at some examples of our
grid here so we're going to start off
with a grid template columns of 1fr1fr
we're just saying
i want you to make a grid i want each of
those columns to just be one fraction of
whatever you've got and we've got
this
i mean
yay but like
let's not really throw a party for that
specific layout it's fine it's fine it's
fine
um
but now let's say that we're going to
take this thing and basically shorthand
it so we can just go like repeat 4 1fr
and now we can make uh this thing um so
this is something where for example if
you're looking for any sort of like css
framework which specifically is giving
you a grid structure like this is the
thing that you can use to supersede all
of that if i want the idea of a four
column layout i can just go
columns equals four
uh repeat four columns equals five
repeat five columns equal six repeat six
like i can just make that thing short
handed without any other framework
involved
but now we've got the idea of actually
mixing uh our column so if we've got
we're going to start off with a 200
pixel column then two additional
fractions and then by doing that and
just giving it these html elements
uh that's going to give it this
so now we've got the idea of something
where we could say you know we've got
maybe a sidebar we've got a header we've
got like different kind of content
sections and we and we want to specify
like where these things are going
neat
but now let's take this
so in this case i'm going to say that i
got a grid template columns and i want
that to repeat
240 pixels
so i'm going to say hey browser i don't
really know how big you are at this
point and i'm not really that keen to
ask
what i want to tell you is that i want
you to take this space and fill it up
with a bunch of 240 pixel columns
as many as you like and then wrap that
thing around
and if i tell that to the browser the
browser go like okay well there you go
uh you've got you wanted 240 pixels
there's 240 pixels and we're just gonna
do this now i could be doing this
and resize this thing
and i don't have to rewrite break points
to be doing that because it's just going
to know
this guy wants 240 pixels just keep
slamming those things out
which is all right except for you're
looking at the end of that thing and
you're going well that's not bad except
for the thing that you've you've got
this weird old gap here so maybe you
could do something about that yeah we
can do something about that
we're going to rewrite that spec in just
one line of code
and say okay
i want you to instead repeat auto fill
min max 250 pixels to 1fr so in that
case what we're saying is hey browser i
want you to uh fill this whole thing up
i gotta i got a box and i need you to
just start making columns and what i
know is that i do not want this to be
less than 250 pixels
but if it has to be bigger you know go
ahead and just take that fraction of
whatever
and so by doing that
we'll get uh this layout
now there's an important thing about
this layout is that
if you wrote this in a bunch of
different ways
it would
like require some real break points to
take care of this because you would say
well okay so
if it's on you know if it's on this
width we're going to have
like six columns across if it's on this
width we're going to have five columns
across but just by doing that line and
letting the browser figure out how big
each of those boxes could be we can just
make a fully responsive layout
literally with that one line of code
that's a responsive layout right there
by itself
but we can get even fancier than that
yes yes indeed we can
and one of those ways that we can do
that is by uh
starting to rewrite some of these rules
as far as specific uh child elements
so we're starting off with a grid that
we saw before which is uh just a simple
four column uh grid repeated
but then we're going to say
i'm sort of in a rum move right now so i
want to see some rum drinks so we're
going to highlight that that mojito that
daiquiri that pina colada and then we're
going to say to those ones i actually
want you to span two columns and i want
you to span two rows
and in so doing we can we can take our
regular layout that is single stacked
layout and we can give it that and end
up with this
now these things do not have different
containers each and every one of these
is a sibling of itself but we've said to
specific classes you're allowed to span
two containers or you're allowed to spam
two columns you're allowed to span two
rows you can also say to that thing well
i actually want you
to take and eat up the third column so
if if there's a third column in there
just go ahead and take that and we can
just specify that in all the children um
we can get even slightly fancier though
because i'm going to give you uh just
this piece of html now you can kind of
imagine what this sort of looks like but
we've got a bunch of different drinks
and in each of those drinks we've got
our pina colada our screwdriver a mojito
or whatever and then we've also
specified what those glasses are and so
there's a bunch of different glasses
that are used by you know bartenders not
myself but you know there's a bunch of
different glasses that can be used for
different drinks
and now i want to just rearrange these
glasses and if i wanted to rearrange
these glasses i'd have to write a bunch
of different queries i'd have to write a
bunch of different
um you know
like like php for this or something or i
could just actually start to use order
so we've got this here this is what our
glassware looks like but now i'm going
to say okay well everything that's in a
collins glass that goes first everything
that's in a martini glass that goes
second everything is on a tulip glass
that's going to go third everything
that's in a margarita glass that goes
forth by saying taking that exact same
markup and changing only those values we
can actually go ahead and just rearrange
everything by the actual glass that is
put into
when you're doing this for like like
magazine layouts or something like that
and you've got a situation where like
the ad is supposed to go over here
except for like if it goes down into a
phone it goes over here and you have to
write a whole bunch of wackadoo queries
for that you can do that by just having
a container and then just setting that
order
on different breakpoints changing that
order around however you feel like it or
even you've got a situation where
somebody else wrote the html and you
can't touch the html
so now you've got something that's over
i'm floated on the left side but
actually i need it to be down here you
give that thing a grid and then you just
say well now i want to change the order
of these things and you can just change
the order of things right there in the
css by itself
oh
okay
all right well
you know in any front-end talk like this
kind of thing is going to come up and
the thing is is that this actually isn't
as bad as you might think that it is now
of course the usual caveat of like of
like at this point if you're using like
win 10 win 11
like win 11 doesn't even have it in
there and then win 10 is like uh don't
use this please like actually don't use
this browser it was edge which is fine
just totally fine um but this but this
story is actually pretty good so if we
look at uh the actual grid support uh
we've got a incredible adoption like all
the way across and even getting into the
10 and 11
all we need for that specific thing is
we need prefixes
so
and if we actually look at the um
the market share base of of all of those
things
then
we see first of all we see a lot of
green and secondly
so
much chrome
like
looking at the amount of crop like you
know i'm i'm always into there's so many
great people like that are on the chrome
team and there's so much great
innovation that that google made with
chrome but whenever any browser has this
much of a market share
it's a little concerning
also just over into the uh safari on ios
um
has uh has anyone ever has anyone in
this room ever used like for example
like firefox on safari
no you haven't
this is a fun thing that's actually in
the apple terms of services you can go
ahead and go to the app store and you
can download something that's called
brave and you can download something
that's called chrome and you can
download something that's called firefox
or vivaldi or opera whatever you like
you can do all of those things but that
actual safari renderer is baked in
legally they will not let any other
browser happen and so i've had
situations of trying to debug something
and like i thought this was only i
thought this was only a safari issue it
is but safari is actually just wearing
other clothes a lot of the time kind of
like bugs bunny actually
um
so the takeaways here is that uh ie 10
and 11 as uh it has some support uh you
can definitely do grid stuff uh in ie
1011 but you're gonna probably want to
do some vendor prefix and some text into
that because they had an earlier version
of the spec
if you're an ie9 yeah then that's a
problem
but the other thing that's also in there
is the concept of flex now flex has a
little bit better support
because it is a slightly older spec but
flex is one of those things that
actually
sort of got missed because css came on
or css grid came on this on the stage
and did so many impressive things so
fast that it got a whole bunch of hoopla
and people went oh there was this grid
thing but we don't really care about
that but but flex is actually still very
cool
so even though i've talked about css
grid and even though i would definitely
encourage everybody to try to just uh
bang out a little grid in css grid i do
actually want to bring to your attention
flex as well
so
um
if we do our riker layout uh
and we just want to do that same thing
in flex then
really all we have to do is we're going
to define uh with a little bit more code
we're going to just define the concept
of our rikers and we're going to say
okay so i've got these rikers
and i want that those rikers to wrap
because by default the concept of flex
doesn't want to wrap unless you tell it
that it should wrap
and then the justify content is going to
be spaced between so you can say
um you know you're going to have this
container element there's going to be
stuff in there and there might be space
in the middle
and you can say to flex well you know
you can do
different things with that you can go
ahead and
you can center everything you can do
space between you can do space around so
there's a gap
in the middle but there's also a gap
around it you can stretch stuff inside
of it
um
and then for each riker we're gonna go
back to our calc uh of uh of our width
uh but you'll notice that i didn't
actually use the property of width here
i use the property of flex basis
and the reason why
was that
flex invented this concept of
you know
ish
and so if you're doing a flex container
and you're doing flex elements inside of
it you can actually say well okay so
i've got this thing and i want it to
basically have a basis of you know 300
pixels or whatever but i have i have
opinions about whether this thing gets
to grow or shrink now you're looking at
a zero and a one here but this in this
case this does not need to be a binary
value you can actually say flex shrink
five which means if i've got a bunch of
things and something needs to needs to
shrink that that one of the higher value
of the flex shrink gets to shrink first
but we can say i have a basis and that's
basically what i want you to do
but if things start to get hairy
because you know
a lot of times we you know we still
think about this concept of like
of like there's desktop and then there's
mobile and that's fine but like there's
so much in the middle you know that
like that dealing with just those
concepts of just desktop and mobile
means that there's going to be so much
squishy area in the middle which is real
to everyone's experience because they're
going to have honestly different devices
but also just different layouts and if
you're just doing a hard transition from
like well here's a whole bunch of boxes
and all of these boxes are all like
spread out
but then you get to mobile and it's just
bam it's just a whole bunch of of blocks
down the line like
i get that basis and i definitely get
that like that's how that design seems
to come around but you can actually do
stuff where you can say okay well i want
you to take this design and i want you
to do it just until the point that it
seems that it might break and then when
it gets to the point that it might break
we're going to do some flexibility there
in the middle
flex can be used with or instead of css
grid i would say if you're going to do a
layout and you want to do sort of a grid
based layout you should use grid if you
want to do something that seems like it
needs to be flexible you should use flex
and you should possibly use those
together because a grid can go or a flex
can go in columns or in rows you can use
these things
next to each other work as perfect
siblings
um
we've got uh wait what that was oh yeah
yeah um i want to give you an another
option here of of a layout uh with uh
with our flex and that is just pictures
of bjork
um
and so if i say okay i'm gonna here i'm
gonna have this uh this flex container
i'm gonna have a uh
a flex i want that thing to wrap around
and i'm gonna do some space between
then in that case we've got uh this uh
this gallery of bjork
which crucially contains a whole bunch
of inequal content
and so we can actually
um say
well okay i want you to respect the
actual dimensions of whatever those
might be but for that space in the
middle you know you're a browser go
ahead and figure it out something you
couldn't do really in any other layout
you could not do that in any other
layout
without a whole bunch of very specific
kind of container elements um
vertical centering with flex uh i hope
that you've never or i hope that you
never have had a situation where
somebody has said well i can't really
center that because yes you can you can
always center that you've all the
front-end developers have been able to
do vertical centering for literally 10
years
in the case of flex display flex align
item center justify content center yes
of course you can always always always
vertically center things
this is uh a concept that um
i i
run into every once in a while and it
makes me
genuinely like a little annoyed because
because we're all trying to be better
developers we're all like at something
like ndc to try to learn and to try to
like and to try to like level up our own
experiences and then somebody comes
around with some sort of click bait
like here's nine css and js
libraries you should learn this year
no man play with your kids
like like watch a movie i'm gonna learn
nine different css and js libraries this
year because that's necessary for my
career
absolutely not if you are somebody
that's doing
css and javascript and you are and
that's working for you and you're
enjoying that experience
cool that is not my choice but if that's
the way that you want to run things
that's okay but to everyone else i would
say there's a thing called the cascade
that ends up being really really
important here
so the cascade uh has been explained in
a whole bunch of ways but it is of
course that first c in css and the
cascade i would describe as thus so the
cascade is individual rules
calculated in order
of increasing specificity
with ids getting extreme priority
only beat by inline styles
and important being the nuclear option
so that means that i've got rules uh all
of css is just a series of rules and
sometimes those rules overwrite each
other but but regardless we're just
going to have rules stacked on top of
each other those are going to be
calculated in order which means that if
we've got one rule and another rule
comes later and those rules disagree the
one that happened later all things being
equal that's going to win but
specificity also matters so for example
if i say that a paragraph should be
black but then i say that a paragraph
inside of an article like article space
p
should be read uh then that's gonna win
because that was more specific but even
more specific than that is the concept
of an id because you can you can write
css based on classes or sometimes you
can do it on attributes if you feel like
it
but if you do it on ids which is totally
which is totally valid it will
totally blow things up if if one
if one css class has a score of one an
id is a score of a hundred so if
something is getting a style and and
you're trying to figure out how to beat
that style out if it's an id it's gonna
probably start to win
you can beat it of course by inline
styles which is what the uh
which is what the css and js approach is
also technically what
well no never mind never mind never mind
there was a talk in here about tailwind
and i do like tailwind and so i
shouldn't throw shade
but it is inline styles um and and
finally important is the nuclear option
if you're into a situation where
where um
where
you have to do it you're you're coming
up on a deadline and things are going
bad and you just
need to get this god damn button done
then you just can use important now
everyone would frown on that but what i
would say to you is that if you're in
that situation i want you to make a file
that's actually called shame
in my uh css architecture i have you
know there's there's abstracts there's
base there's layouts there's sections
there's components and then i have a
file called shame
and things happen so i end up writing
files that go into shame but when we go
to production i'll say okay just so you
know
i have nine rules in here and we should
probably take care of them
so i'm going to actually skip past that
because i am starting to run over
because our next talk is happening real
soon
but
if we've got this specific thing
with these rules these rules are going
to conflict and we're going to end up
with this now one of the things that's
really really helpful is when i'm
working on css especially other people's
css junior developers that i'm working
with
what i like to do is just always have
that inspector open because if you've
got that inspector open you can just
look at any specific uh
any specific piece of content and you
can look at that right there and say oh
well okay so
that green is crossed out and the orange
is winning and you can kind of like grok
that cascade just based on uh the actual
um
uh inspector right there
uh a couple things i want to leave you
with uh number one is a really uh uh
really effective uh game for css
selectors called css diner
this is a game by fluke out
and essentially what you have is uh
you're just trying to make a selection
so for example i want to select the
apple on the plate and so i can see that
there is
there's an element called plate and
there's a element called apple i'm going
to go plate
apple
and there we go
i'm going to select the pickle on the
fancy plate so now i've got a plate and
that's got an id of fancy
and that's got a pickle on it
and i'm going to do that
this is i think a really helpful way to
kind of like recognize that specificity
um there's only you know like i think it
mentions up there yeah there's 32 levels
and it is actually a really useful tool
just to just to really hone in your
selectors and figure out what those
selectors should look like
another one i want to give you is uh
it's called flexbox froggy and so this
is a game where
uh by thomas park and we're just trying
to put the frogs
actually on the lily pads so
we've got our layout here and we want to
go
uh
justify content space
around
oops space
between
oh no
center
um
so we've got a situation where we can
just kind of like play with these
properties usually there's going to be
kind of tool tips at the top going like
here's kind of where i'm trying to lead
you down and we're just going to use
these uh use these skills to try to like
just get all of our uh our frogs on the
lily pads really really cool for helping
out uh and learning some more about
flexbox uh similarly uh another one
called grid garden uh
by the exact same guy a very similar
concept you're gonna have a bunch of
different vegetables uh and you control
the water so you're just trying to make
uh a grid layout of water that's gonna
touch all of the vegetables and only all
of the vegetables
codepen uh is a site that's been going
around for a long time it is not
specifically a
a css site it's kind of an everything
site there is uh you know the after code
sandbox came around codepen kind of like
extended out their things so they do
like view applets and stuff like that uh
but it was started by chris coyer of css
tricks so it is a very uh css friendly
thing um but you can for example just
look at and and i've got
so i just have a search here on css only
which is just something that i look at
and you know a lot of uh uh front-end
design or front-end developers compete
of just figuring out how to do really
really insane stuff without css or with
without any javascript whatsoever um
sometimes there's a thing with like with
like checkbox hacks or whatever um but
it does create a whole bunch of uh very
very cool
approaches
i think i saw one over here
i mean it's neat
there's a lot of really neat things that
you can do with only css and without
having to get um
really complicated with your stack
um
finally uh is a game that i'm personally
obsessed with uh it's fantastic it's
called css battle and css battle is as
uh you have to draw exactly the picture
that's on the screen
so for example some of the live battles
right here we've got uh
we've got we have to make the skull
but
you have to do this
with code golf
which means that you have to solve the
drawing getting a hundred percent match
on the drawing itself
but using as few key strokes as possible
so it's not only a a lesson in css it's
also a lesson in how amazingly fault
tolerant both html or css is like the
amount of broken ass that you can
write and the browser will go like uh
i'll try to figure it out is incredible
uh css battle is such a cool look into
just how bad
you can write your html and still have
it render
so we started off like this and i and i
saw some hands and i'm hoping that by
the end of it that we've thought about
this language we've thought about the
powers of this language we've thought
about a language that is
useful
and cool
and impressive
and beautiful because i think that css
is an incredibly beautiful language uh
that i would encourage all of us to just
be spending a little bit more time in
so that's uh the end of my talk uh my
name is lemon and thank you so very much
one last thing i wanted to mention is i
know that as developers we do love
stickers and god knows that i do love
stickers so if you'd like yourself a
lemon sticker i'm just going to spread
these all out here you go ahead and take
as many as you like
i am available for any conversation you
want to have css breakdancing or
otherwise
thanks again enjoy the rest of the
conference